here Don pacle this is Senator Ron
Johnson who of course has been at the
Helm of the Senate's investigations into
Biden Family Inc Senator is this the
beginning of a media Pig pile on Biden
what's their motivation here I doubt it
if it is it's a a minimal one uh to
quote that political article the
president hasn't been shown to have
committed wrongdoing but political
review of recent developments cast doubt
on several statements I mean he lied
through his teeth he lied to the
American public to become president of
the United States you don't consider
that wrongdoing so I would consider this
is a modified limited hangout kind of
the Watergate scandal type where it's
the Press is just barely dragging itself
to some admission that well you know
he's not the perfect guy the the man of
integrity we tried to convey the
American public do you agree that's
really the only leverage they have with
President Biden were they really serious
that they had to move on from him for
2024 that his family is what he really
cares about especially his
son he's going to do what's best for Joe
Biden I think we've we we've seen that I
mean the the the millions he's amassed
in public office I mean we're really not
investigating that as well uh my my
guess is I think the evidence will be so
overwhelming and again his performance
as president is so awful that I think
they'll cast him aside but let's face it
so you think they are going to cast I
think he has almost 0% chance of being
their their nominee but I want to point
out it's not just President Biden's
governance this is Democrat governance
that's D destroying this country
now special counsel David Weiss is
sitting down for a voluntary transcribed
interview with the house Judiciary
Committee tomorrow Senator his
spokesperson told Fox that Weiss is
prepared to take this unprecedented step
of testifying before the conclusion of
his investigation to make clear that
he's had and continues to have full
authority over his investigation and to
bring charges in any jurisdiction
Senator what should those Republicans be
asking full Authority what to interfere
in the election you know what's not
getting enough play is Senator
grassley's whistleblower he wrote a
letter to FBI director Ray and attorney
general Garland where he talks about his
whistleblower saying the FBI had 40
confidential human sources you know they
also established this foreign influence
task force uh its primary task was to
find out where there was derogatory
information on Joe Biden or Hunter Biden
and then Mike saf calls it catch and
kill you know go and basically say that
evidence is Russian disinformation it's
that same task force that had an un
listing briefing unlisted briefing to
Senator Grassley and I where we said
they told us we were targets of Russian
disinformation this is August of 2020 so
again this is pretty well documented and
let's face it the FBI started its pre-
sabotaging the hunter B laptop the day
they picked it up but they actually
think it's okay do they not for the
president's family to make money off of
the Biden name when Biden was in office
that that mean most Democrats apparently
think that's just totally fine my guess
that's true because all they care about
is power but uh I'm not sure the FBI
believes that but there are high-ups in
the FBI that are such partisan actors
that they did everything they could to
interfere in our investigation and in
Weiss's investigation as well now Hunter
is blaming disinformation for his
family's troubles and the questions into
um his business dealing saying my
struggles and my mistakes have been
fodder for a vile and sustained
disinformation campaign against
President Biden and an allout
annihilation of his reputation your
response if you've ever seen the Marco
Polo report which is just you know
pictures and and emails off of his
laptop uh there's hard evidence of
wrongdoing and one thing drives me nuts
is the fact that he solicited and and
used women that that were part of an
international sex trafficking ring I
guess that's all forgetting guess I
guess that's not wrongdoing either I
guess it's not wrongdoing to collect
millions of dollars from China and then
cancel the China initiative which is the
Department of Justice program to
investigate Chinese theft of our
intellectual property and universities
one of the first acts President Biden
when he came into office is that a sign
of compromise I would think it is are
you worried that our China policy is
being written in fact by China given
what's going on absolutely remember the
whole outrage over possible Trump
collusion with Russia was if we had a
president that had connections to a
foreign power that could compromise that
President well that was a complete false
narrative this complete hoax perpetrated
by the Hillary Clinton campaign the FBI
knew that now we're doing a reset of our
China Rel relationship after money's
flow into the Biden family it's all a
coincidence Senator I think you're being
very mean Senator great to see you
tonight as always thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else